welcome to philanthropy in action where
we uncover the wonderful stories of
people who give their time talent and
treasure to change the world these are
stories of philanthropy
I am maxim thorn and I teach
philanthropy in action at Yale
University Ingo Reichenbach is the vice
president from Yale University who's in
charge of all of our fundraising Thank
You Inger for joining us and we also
have these wonderful dedicated and
brilliant Yale students with us I'd like
to ask them to introduce themselves
starting with Joan I'm Joan gasps I'm a
senior from Dallas Texas and I'm double
majoring in International Studies and
women gender sexuality studies hi my
name is Leslie bol I'm a junior from
Arlington Virginia I'm a political
science major and I'm studying
international development hi my name is
Christina Lee I'm a junior from San Jose
California and I study history hi my
name is Robert rich Nikki I'm a freshman
from New York City and I'm studying
computer science I'm Alan banks and I'm
a sophomore from Richland Washington and
I'm studying chemical engineering I'm
Carl Chen I'm a junior from outside Los
Angeles
I'm studying sociology thank you inga
you have done something quite remarkable
very recently in the worst economic
climate since the Great Depression you
have closed a capital campaign for Yale
University raising over 3.8 billion
dollars how did you manage those
challenges and how did you succeed well
I have to admit it was an adventure and
not one that we had planned for you know
I've been in development for a long time
and when you have a campaign there's
always a recession in there so you kind
of you know go with the flow there but
this one was so different as we all you
know experienced and I will never forget
October 2008 which is when everything
came to a grinding halt now luckily we
were way ahead of our schedule for the
campaign we were in year three already
and we ran about a year ahead of
schedule but because we were thinking we
were doing so well in June of 2008 we
increased the goal
three-and-a-half billion and then came
October what was so new and different
and scary about that time was that this
financial crisis was something that was
completely unpredictable and what would
happen next it created a tremendous
sense of uncertainty nobody knew where
this was going
nobody knew where the free fall would
end and that was the most mysterious
because obviously our donors even those
who may not have been completely you
know affected by this crisis there was
the uncertainty they didn't know what
was going to happen and so for about two
years it was just almost impossible to
get people to make new commitments now
obviously we were still you know
determined to reach the goal and so we
shifted focus and we really shifted
focus on not the many many many
different campaign priorities that we
had but we focused on the core we said
okay we need gifts to financial aid we
need gifts for professorships gifts that
build the endowment and help in this
financial crisis and we took a you know
a very tough look at what we could
accomplish and what not so you have
heard the president speak about you know
we stopped our capital projects you know
almost all building you know got stopped
but we've we figured out there were a
few that we might be able to finish and
so we said we concentrate on those so
the the secret behind it was that we
were very very focused as a staff now
the secret behind the relationship with
our donors was that we didn't drop them
when the bad times came we initially
they didn't want to see us because they
thought we wanted to ask him for a gift
but once they realized that we just
wanted to maintain the relationships
stay in touch express that we understand
that this is a difficult time you know
we were able to stay involved have them
they involved with Yale and then the
last year of the campaign happened and
somehow people either were used to the
new normal or they you know they saw
where things were going for themselves
and they were so dedicated to Yale that
they didn't want to miss participating
in the campaign so while the first two
years of the crisis we are giving
dropped significantly in the last year
of the campaign our donors gave eight
hundred and sixty two million dollars
this is by far the largest amount that
was ever given to Yale in a given year
and you know it shows the commitment
that our donors had so I have to say the
credit does not go to the staff the
credit goes to our donors to the land
surface and I remember seeing a graph
for people who are involved in
fundraising especially for large
organizations I remember seeing a graph
that someone said which was a flat graph
the line was flat and they said this is
the new up you on the other hand and I
really want to bring this home you broke
your your own record right because from
a three billion dollar campaign to a 3.5
billion you actually brought in three
point eight one billion that was a
remarkable achievement but it also
highlights something which is about the
capacity that that our donors had to do
this and the capacity that Yale had to
manage those relationships how is that
replicable for other entities in the
country you use the key word for this
and that's relationships you know what I
see today in philanthropy happening
often is what I would call transactional
you know I know you have money so I come
to you and ask you for a gift and you
give me something then I turn away and
go to the next person that is not what
we define as philanthropy because
philanthropy really
a relationship and it is a relationship
that we set out to establish in a
university to establish with our donors
our alumni for life so we are not in it
for you know just upon gift and then we
drop people we are in it for you know
keeping our alumni involved with the
University and as they get to know the
behind the scenes of the university you
know what are the struggles what are the
priorities what is the vision what do we
want to accomplish you know they
understand that it takes money and those
who have money you know then voluntarily
participating and participate in it much
more generously than if you are just
asked for money and you know here we go
John you have a question so picking off
that idea of relationships with people I
think yeah we talk about a lot of things
but talking about money is a sensitive
topic and and there's a question about
being able to ask people for money
without imposing or maintain a sense of
authenticity in the relationship not
feeling like it's just because that
other person has money so I was
wondering if you could talk to us maybe
about an example of a conversation
you've had with a big donor and how you
maintain that relationship knowing that
that money is the thing that holds that
relationship together I wouldn't say
that money is what holds the
relationship together because then it
would be so targeted on a goal and you
know then the sincerity the the
seriousness about the relationship you
know would be compromised I mean you
really I believe have to be committed to
what you are fundraising for you have to
believe in that so there are certain
things that I would feel very
comfortable raising money for and that's
higher education there are other things
where my passion isn't as strong it's
there's interest but I don't feel as
passionate about it as I do about higher
education so you let those relationships
develop
and that's the other thing you know you
can't say it takes one visit and then
you have a relationship it takes much
more you know what it takes to develop a
real good friendship a really
relationship so you don't focus on money
you focus on the person's interests and
you focus on where these interests may
have a counterpart a match at Yale and
so you let it you let it develop slowly
and you know just the other day because
you asked for an example of an of a
conversation I was meeting with the
president with somebody who for whom
this was the first meeting with Yale
it's not an yel alumnus and so I
happened to be there a little earlier
than the president because he was the
weather was terrible and the taxes
didn't drive right and so I happened to
be by myself with this donor for the
first 15 minutes I say donor he's not a
donor yet and we had you know and I
could see he asked me immediately
are you the development person I said
yes I'm from development and I could see
that he had a certain expectation of
what I would do next and I just talked
up a conversation with him he is an
amazingly interesting person and it was
very easy to you know to to get in
engage in a conversation well afterwards
a day later I got feedback from the
fourth person who was there who came
with him and he said you know he was
very pleased to meet both of us
obviously he was very pleased to meet
the president but he also commented that
I was very different from other
fundraisers who always immediately go
toward talking about a gift and in my
view that's not philanthropy that's not
enabling people to do what they want to
do what they can do with their resources
that are for some people are incredibly
big and for others not so big so my role
is to facilitate something but through a
relationship that is truly honest
and I have a role from a rule for myself
you know three strikes and you're out if
I don't if a donor doesn't connect with
me if I'm not able to connect with a
donor then I say it's probably better
for the institution that somebody else
steps in the changing climate offer
opportunities unexpected opportunities
so for example there is a national
debate going on about whether people
should even go to college and whether
snobs we're snobs so all of us are at a
university getting undergraduate degrees
or advanced degrees or our graduates so
obviously as a person who's curious as
you said passionately about higher
education this debate would trouble you
I would think as it as an institution
how do you interact when the climate is
changing around us in the in these kinds
of ways it is a troubling a troubling
situation but you know with every
troubling situation there is also an
opportunity and I think the dimension or
the comment that we heard recently that
it is not wish to you know aspire to a
university or college degree is a
different facet of another question that
has been around for a longer time and
that is why should I give to a wealthy
institution and Yale happens to be a
wealthy institution so this is a
question that we have heard a lot that
we have heard you know from in primarily
from individuals who really are not
involved and lack a certain
understanding of you know what private
institutions are about so you know how
do you think about you know why should
you give to Yale it's so wealthy could
do anything it wants to do I think if
you there is somewhere in there a
legitimate question and a legitimate
question
there is tell us what you do with your
wealth tell us you know are you using
your wealth for the public good are you
using your wealth to do something good
in society or are you squandering it by
I don't know doing what with it now when
you when you look at the question from
that perspective you know it becomes a
lot easier to explain why people should
give to an institution like Yale or
others but first of all you can start
out there are two models of funding
higher education right public and
private so you look at what but you know
you compare the two systems and what
striking is in every survey that you
read you know that ranks institutions
you have to go through 20 institutions
at least to come to the first public
institution the last survey it was
ranked number 22 it was Berkeley only
then do public institutions begin to now
look at Berkeley that's an incredibly
interesting situation Berkeley and the
California State University system was
the treasurer of higher education of
public higher education and some from
you are from California so you know
what's happening there when the
political climate shifts when budgets
get tied you know people don't hesitate
to cut higher education and what what
the California state system is going
through right now is really tragic
because it was such a stellar you know
system now these systems you know so a
subject to you know the vagaries of
political you know developments the
bakeries of of economic developments on
the private side
you know the individuals decided who
founded this institution said you know
I'm gonna rely on myself I'm gonna rely
on a different system I'm gonna start up
this institution then I charge something
out to those people who want to be here
but then I want that everybody who
graduates understands that you know they
have an opportunity maybe even a little
bit of a moral obligation but at least
an opportunity to to hand over this
institution to the next generation in a
better way so that the institution is
better off and that's what endowments
are endowments are nothing but gifts
that were given and are well managed so
you know an institution like Yale with
the big endowment it has is capable of
paying a much more impact of impactful
role than other institutions you know
when you look at advances in science it
costs money you know 300 years ago
nobody talked about gene sequencing well
today if you want to be a player you
have to do that but through these
advances and through investment in
science this is also what fuels the
economic development the economic health
of our country you know and aside from
the fact that you know it's always good
to educate people who are capable of
providing good leadership when they go
out in the world and then one thing I
just want to mention to that is you know
the private institutions have been a
major factor in social mobility because
when you think about it sometimes it is
less expensive to come to a place like
Yale or and private institution than to
go to a public institution
why because philanthropists donors have
understand that and have given a lot of
money to fight
you know I see students dying to jump in
on on this conversation but I wanted to
hardly let it start over I know students
are dying to get in on this conversation
but I wanted to talk about what you just
said which is my personal experience I
remember mmm as an immigrant child to
the United States when my aunt who was
taking me around to various universities
my first year and took me to City
College in New York and took me to Pace
University and and some others and you
know she had lived at an immigrant life
and she had gone to City College and she
felt this is how one does it and I
remember I was eligible for some
financial aid but I would have to take a
full-time job nevertheless and pay my
own mm-hm
many other things that make it possible
and then this is prior to me applying to
the Ivy League which thought was so
beyond what one could afford and the
reality was when I got my package Yale
was affordable in a way that City
College which is supposed to be the one
that should be affordable for us but it
was not and it most people find this so
hard to believe and including my family
that it was actually much more doable
for me to go to Yale than to go to the
local colleges and I think a lot of
people don't realize that what Carl has
been dying to jump into this
conversation Carl yeah I'm a little
interested in when when you just kind of
gave us the idea of why someone should
donate to Yale I was wondering how
receptive your donors are to your
message that you just gave right now
what kind of donors are you appealing to
and is it like really wealthy
businessmen or is it more like people
who have made their fortune in like
entrepreneurs
maybe at law or something or and kind of
also do they have their own agendas when
they come in they want specific changes
or do they just want to follow the
university's lead mm-hmm that's a really
interesting question and the first part
you know what kinds of donors do we work
with we try to work with you know the
whole alumni group obviously not
everybody is you know willing to engage
or so but you know through our Annual
Fund you know everybody has an
opportunity to give a small gift and you
know they add up their up significantly
we have you know we raised about twenty
six million dollars in unrestricted
gifts do the annual fund but then we
work with individuals who have you know
capacity to get $50,000 or $100,000
million or all the way up to you know
nine figure gifts so we try to you know
cover everybody and even we are working
with parents meaning not parents who
themselves went to Yale but parents
whose only connection to Yale is through
their their kids who are currently here
and you know obviously those individuals
who give us you know we have parents who
gave us ten million dollars in addition
to paying tuition and all of that so we
try to to work with as many donors as we
can but it's a car you you talk about a
very intriguing issue and that is you
know it doesn't donor come with ideas or
you know it's a donor just waiting for
us to tell them this is what we like you
to do well obviously you know it's a
it's a it's a you know it costs the
board the university always has its
priorities its vision etc and obviously
when we go out we would like to you know
make a compelling case that individuals
should you know give to that but when
somebody has the capacity and the
interest of making an extraordinary a
large gift you know they
tend to come with their own ideas and
then it is becoming a very interesting
interesting you know kind of negotiation
and I negotiate is not the right word it
becomes a very interesting conversation
that sometimes may take very long to
complete because of course you know if
if I have a hundred million dollars to
give away I probably gave it some
thought what I want to do with it and
you know I have a dream I I want
something you know to happen and I think
Yale is the best place for it to happen
so you know what is there to talk about
and we said well you know we have these
other needs over here or it really and
so and so forth but you know we have to
remember you know the beginning of
philanthropy the Golden Age of
philanthropy you know it was the big
donors the big years who made things
happen so we better take you know
seriously when people come with big
ideas and say rather than saying well if
we can't if we we have to do it exactly
this way I we don't want to do it but to
think about so what is behind the idea
you know what does this person really
want to accomplish and how do I you know
what is here where this would fit and so
you you kind of try in those
conversations to for both sides to move
toward one another and come to something
in the end and that's important that
both parties are really happy about so
two of you do international studies you
know we have the Jackson Institute that
was funded through a gift that was the
idea of the donor and you know while
Yale was interested and heavily invested
in internationalization at the time you
know we were more thinking of finding
scholarships to send students abroad you
know in the summertime or you know
getting international students here
thinks of that nature so we didn't have
the establishment of an institute on our
list
but the donors made a compelling case
and it forced us it was to Yale to think
about it and you know by the time the
agreement was signed you know both the
donors as well as Yale had moved from
where they were when we started the
conversation to something where
everybody is very happy and and I have
heard president xi talk about the
Jackson Institute as the best academic
startup he's ever seen you know so it
worked
yeah I mean that's really interesting
that you going back to the first part of
the question how there's so many
different types of donors that you I
think as students when we walk around
campus you know we hear about the
Jackson Institute or bass lie but we're
sterling so we hear all these big names
and we think you know only the big
donors really make a difference at Yale
I guess and it feels like that maybe I
don't know why I don't know if you have
a lot of conversation with students
sometimes but it feels like there's
maybe a little bit of a a culture to
pursue monetary success to kind of like
there's this expectation that I don't
have to like give back to Yale somehow
later on or give back to the world
somehow and like what's the best way to
do that and it feels like there's a
little bit of like a pressure to kind of
be that big name donor a little bit I
hope that you can convince yourself that
there shouldn't be that pressure I think
the only thing that yell expects of you
is that you become a leader in whatever
you are going to do you know and you
know many people find their passion in
social service or something or in
environmental issues certainly we have a
lot of schools here whose alumni are not
participating in this you know Wall
Street you know kind of game look at we
have an excellent Drama School I was
shocked when I learned you know how
these you know these are the best of the
best you know you know coming actors you
know they still have to waitress after
they you know and be waiters after they
graduate you know they usually are not
good
be expected to become but they become
leaders in in the arts music school the
same nursing school you know what would
we do without the nursing school it's an
incredibly interesting school because
it's not what we think it is it is much
more influence you know much more
impactful on the higher level take
forestry and environmental studies when
you go into environmental issues you are
not going to be one of the top earners
in the country Divinity School so you
know actually you know a lot of of the
schools and all the things we teach are
not meant to lead people to a life that
will end up with great economic reward
and so we couldn't possibly expect that
you know these big gifts would come from
there I think when feelin's philanthropy
really works then everybody does
contribute what they can and what they
feel passionate about I think that would
be successful philanthropy and I tell
you one other thing in the in the crisis
you know before we started the campaign
our Annual Fund volunteers your class
volunteers
their biggest concern was you know with
these big numbers is our $100 gift is
our you know small contribute is that
gonna make any difference if we call
account is it gonna do anything and I
assured them it always is important but
you know the global crisis really you
know made believers out of them because
when you have every year twenty six
million dollars that you can spend where
you need it that's you know we need a
half a billion dollars of endowment to
to generate that so it does count it did
count and it made a huge difference
having that is is there attention though
when you are having these conversations
between what Carl said which is adding
your name to it because I think years
ago for example I think it was a
conversation to heal
way before our time about should
colleges
where the name of donors was in my time
that was and the colleges do not bear
the name of donors but other things do
like the best library the Jackson
Institute and and others given what Carl
just said which is students may have a
feeling of altering their lives choices
based on that is their attention and how
do those conversations actually go I can
see that there could be attention and I
can see that you know when you are
surrounded by these big names etc that
you know it might be a little bit
intimidating or an expectation but you
know the other thing is there we have
had philanthropists here's whose names
is not on anything so one always has the
choice of giving anonymously or
privately if one wants to escape that
you know if this person did that and I
ought to be doing that but you know in
Germany that debate is also you know
when people give their Germany does not
have a culture of philanthropy at least
not in the American sense but they are
trying to introduce this now and so a
big issue is you know significant donors
there are significant donors but very
few admit to it
so you my alma mater is the universe of
Heidelberg so you get an announcement
from there that they are they are able
to do this that or the other because of
a gift and that's all and you wonder
what can I believe here you know
transparency so if somebody's willing to
put their name on the gift that helps
everybody I know we always say it helps
you know encouraging other people to
give that's one thing but you also want
to know you know where does the
university get the resources from to do
what it is doing I think that sense of
transparency is very important so I am
four names on buildings but I respect
everybody's
desire to be private about it anonymous
about it but it is you know there are
many dimensions to to this question
Christina I know that you're dying to
getting on this conversation definitely
I wanted to continue this conversation
about anonymous giving versus having big
names attached to the nation's we
recently read a book called Rambam
slaughter where the author argued based
on the philosophy of my mom and he's
saying that anonymous giving is actually
perhaps the most noble form of giving
the best form of giving but obviously
we're an institution that's marked with
names as Carl touched upon earlier so
how do you reconcile these two
perspectives does Yale value anonymous
donations in a different way than these
big-name donations and do you engage
with these different types of donors
differently well you know Yale value is
you know anonymous gifts and gifts that
are named in the same way because it's a
gift and it's given in the spirit to
help the University I say to me it's a
personal choice what a donor should do
if he or she feels comfortable having
their name on it I think it is good
because it reminds others that you know
this did not grow on trees you know this
did not come from nowhere people
actually took responsibility to to
nurture this place and give it the
resources so that it could become what
it is but at the same time you know an
anonymous gift can have the same impact
I just would not be completely
comfortable with only anonymous giving
because it just would raise in my view
questions and should raise questions
with others about transparency and you
know what is the financial situation do
we ever flip that question which is a
donor that might have a background that
is a little bit complicated or
disturbing that we would prefer not to
be transparent about
I would not advise them to going that
road you know part of why we are so
relationship based in our fundraising is
we want to know the donor
we don't want Yale to be used for a
purpose that is not philanthropic and so
the donors who have made these be gifts
to Yale they all have a 10 20 30 40 50
year relationship with Yale so we know
them and they know us and it is a good
match I don't think we want to be in a
position where you know Yale is going to
be used for you know selfish purposes
for publicity or something like that
Cristina how do you gauge the
philanthropic motives of a donor is it
through what they tell in conversation
is about about what type of careers they
pursue how do you gauge how honorable
their motives are I think you through
conversation is how you determine this
best and as I said through a
long-standing relationship you know over
a long time you know they get to know us
with all the things that we might not be
so happy having out there but we also
get to know them and it's like whether
relationship with friends you know you
get to know them even so you know you
couldn't exactly tell where you exactly
you know figured out where they are but
you know it is important that you know
philanthropy you know be exercised or
that we call philanthropy what
philanthropy truly is and not marketing
is not philanthropy you know getting
visibility getting you know
something for it it's not romantic are
you a saleswoman
I completely object to the
characterization of being a salesperson
and I'm but I'm glad you bring it up
because this is you know what I see so
often people say oh you are you are
selling yeah I'm not selling Yale I'm
making possible for for an institution
that has a lot to offer in terms of
service to society and to a person who
have the resources to do something there
to get together and do it in an
efficient way
that's not marketing that's not selling
that's that's making a deal
no that's enabling people to treat their
dreams and for institutions like Yale or
other universities to really become
better and better and better so so is
there a way you can capture what you
said are you so you're not a deal maker
you're not a sales person you are a
facilitator and mediator person who
brings people together
very new Leslee responsibility which
we're going to be talking about a little
bit in class today I was just wondering
do you think the Yale corporation
specifically has any kind of moral
obligation or responsibility to give
back to public good beyond just Yale for
instance do you think he'll has any sort
of moral obligation towards New Haven as
being part of the New Haven community oh
definitely you know the New Haven
community is a great example when
president Levin became president
I mean Yale was a poster child for a
number of things and one was it for the
terrible area it was surrounded by and
you know it was a recognition that a
great university cannot exist unless the
community it is in also participates in
it so Yale has done an enormous amount
of contributions of help you know the
economic development was
all a much of it was driven through Yale
through year resources whoo Yale
you know people pose Alexander for
example he has done a lot in that
respect beyond that there's a lot that
is not so visible like our payments or
they get getting the Apple Store here
that was a great you know contribution
to the to the community and it was only
because Yale was behind it and he made
it happen and then there are a lot of in
you know not visible things so for
example the involvement with the school
system here you know yeah aside the new
year are they the new haven promise and
so Yale is going to pay for every
student who has you know so it meets
certain criteria qualifies pays for his
or her tuition I think that's a
tremendous involvement and investment in
the community we also have through there
so some gifts to the music school
we have a tremendous outreach program of
the music students in the local schools
you know they have academies they teach
you know music because that's the first
thing that gets caught you know so so
Yale it's really Yale and its students
and faculty are investing quite a bit in
New Haven and definitely feel that
social responsibility was it difficult
to keep that same focus on social
responsibility going during the
recession no there was no there was no
cut in this we signed the new your we
signed there and we haven't promised
during the recession so that was you
know that commitment to the to the
communities here why do you think that
other institutions don't follow that
same sort of integrity which is to hold
on to their commitments to their social
responsibility into in the tough times
well I can't speak for you know the
thinking or what happened at other
institutions
I would think that
you know universities by and large are
conscious of it and if they are and they
get even minded being that they are
tax-exempt entities that do not pay
taxes on their real estate so you know
there is a sense that you have to make
contributions in a different way whether
in a in tough economic times you know
you have to kind of retreat on the
margins a little bit might happen but I
don't think any university that's in a
in an urban setting can afford to ignore
its surroundings there is a self
preserve an interest involved in that as
well I have to say because you know you
just have to make these contributions or
else I think we would strengthen the
case that university should not be
tax-exempt so to continue with the idea
of social responsibility a sense of
social responsibility as motivating
philanthropy earlier we had the
opportunity to speak with a founder of
the extra town Foundation which funds a
high school in a village in Guatemalan
so what might you say to a donor who is
interested in education but is like
trying to make that decision between
Yale and that other organization and
what do you think it's fair to sort of
can't try to categorize the morality of
one over another or like to say that one
donation could be as a potential or
should be considered more philanthropic
death definitely no to the latter
statement philanthropies philanthropy
whether it's big or small whether it's
here or there so I would you know
there's there's no question about that
but U is a very interesting example
because I have another example to that
and that is when we launched the
campaign in 2006 the the public phase I
you know we organized a multimedia show
to show a little bit what the campaign
was about and we featured some of the
students at the time so it was all
before your time and I had we had two
young women there who founded Mercado
global
you've heard of it and you know they
found it while they were students here
and they got the training and teaching
to do that here and last I heard it's
still thriving they are not together one
you know one was in from India and she
went back to her home and the other
young woman involved is still at it
and what she is doing is exactly what
you are describing they help women in
cooperatives there too with their crafts
develop sales channels for it help us it
designed a little bit so that it can be
sold you had people want to buy it here
and all and that the proceeds all go to
pay the women obviously for the things
but the profits all go into the school
system there so that every kid in that
co-operative can go to school now these
are doing the same things right and but
funded through two different ways so you
could say you know I can accomplish the
same goal by investing in a person
through a scholarship or that I enable
this person to come to an institution
where they can you know develop these
skills and develop this leadership and
you know they both said they learned a
lot from their master who helped them
and you know at first said what makes
you think you can do that that was his
first thing and that's very Vaughn and
they got into it so you know you can
accomplish the same things in different
ways and I think it's entirely your
decision you know where you want to do
it so would you say that making donors
aware of those like individual
investments that Yale is responsible for
making is one of your more effective
tools for kind of encouraging donor
participation the most effective tool is
to find out what people are passionate
about what they really care about
and then match it with a need at the
University you can't turn somebody who
is interested in helping young children
you can't compel this person to give a
you know and a gene sorter or something
like that it just doesn't work so you
have to be sensitive and have to find
out what is it that this person wants to
accomplish you know what is history more
her dream and then show them that they
can accomplish this dream at Yale so you
almost have a philanthropic approach to
philanthropy then absolutely you are
talking about how a lot of the money
that's donated to Yale goes toward
research that furthers different
scientific developments and how a lot of
money goes toward community projects and
in New Haven area so obviously a lot of
the money goes toward like social good
but do you ever feel as though like a
very successful campaign could lead to a
development of a lot of our pursuit of
luxuries that isn't sustainable at the
university Tommy first what you mean by
luxuries when just opportunities for the
students and like just to make life much
more comfortable than it needs to be
where this money could go toward some
other area I can't say in this
particular campaign that was probably
not the problem because at the same time
where we tried to raise the money we
also lost six billion dollars of our
endowment so you know there the campaign
didn't even make up for what we had lost
so we are still in a time of you know
where we have to shrink you know the
organization I think there is a
legitimate conversation to be had about
you know how much comfort you know what
is important for for
you know for a student is it the sense
of community is it the great academics
is it you know having wonderful
facilities etc I think we can we could
argue a little bit about you know how
well-equipped should residential college
be or you know I think there are voices
on both sides of it
but but at the same time in the in our
campaign we had primarily academic goals
to strengthen you know to branch out
into new areas that we didn't teach it
to secure much more financial aid
because you know we were almost fully
endowed for financial aid before the
crash we spent about sixty million
dollars a year on it and we had almost
as much income from scholarship
endowments and with the financial crash
what happened is not only you know
did we lose part of that endowment but
we had much more students who became
eligible who needed it so now we moved
from sixty million a year to about a
hundred million a year in financial aid
expenditures and so we we wanted to
raise money you know for for that etc so
that campaign and the and the crash kind
of I think did not allow for this kind
of stuff to happen but I can see that we
all have to be careful and I think
student voices to be heard in that would
be good inga you said of several themes
that I find compelling one is about the
longevity of an institution like year
over time and you mentioned about how
the endowment allows yields who in some
ways operate without the pressures of a
particular political moment which
Berkeley and other state universities
have suffered
or they can benefit depending on a
particular moment while at the same time
it has ongoing operational issues that
are affected is is there a a balance
that is reached that sometimes are murky
when I say that I talk about say a time
when I was here mm-hmm
when we were as an institution dealing
with issues that were being raised
internationally around our fate and
investments in South Africa that that
had a that were taking people in many
different directions how how does a
university a great one like this deal
with those kinds of tensions between
endowment for long term existence short
term kneel and big global issues well a
university deals for these issues by
having a really good president I think
you know to strike that balance between
what is core what is crucial what should
we never give up is important and I
think it's also fairly easy obviously a
great university needs great faculty and
it's great students and so how do we how
do we maintain that and how do we
continue to enhance it and when you
think of it that way then you can think
of a lot of different ways of how you
have to go about it and philanthropy can
can play a role in it I think we have to
be careful about things that may be very
short-term you know so for example one
particular major is running up you know
everybody wants to be that and there's
this other major over here that nobody
wants so we could say oh if I were a
businessman I'll put more money into
this and I'll get rid of that but you
know things in science in humanities so
design they don't always work that way
and all of a sudden
this goes down again and this goes up in
so you have to have a sense of what kind
of an institution you want to be and
maintain those programs those values
throughout the you know the shifts thank
you thank you Inger Thank You students
this has been philanthropy in action
I am maxim thorn Inga Reichenbach the
vice president of Yale University's
fundraising shared with us her passion
for higher education and what it takes
to make a great institution and how much
we depend on our donors and the
community to do what it takes to invest
in our community and in the world now
what are you going to do to change the
world
you